it's a pretty well-known fact that these
days video games are getting easier
there are more cutscenes more waypoints
and more crutches built into the game
while these games often include a hard
mode it doesn't really count for much
when you have control over the
difficulty if you're getting frustrated
most developers offer a way to reduce
the difficulty so that you don't stop
playing their game however while this
video is related to difficulty and the
casualization of gaming that's not what
it's about this is about an aspect of
game design that I enjoy in games but I
don't really see it in many I don't know
if it has a better name but here's what
I'm calling it implicit game design it's
when a game doesn't tell you how to
complete an objective hell it may even
not tell you what the objective is it's
what a central game mechanic is hidden
but still in effect its implicit its
cryptic and it's actually part of the
game to puzzle it out now in case you
still don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about
here's an example lately I've been
playing a game called star seed pilgrim
here's some footage from where I'm
currently at in the game chances are you
won't be able to make heads or tails of
what's going on it probably all looks
random to you but in the game right now
and thinking rapidly and thinking about
the consequence of every move I've
actually just made a major screw-up here
but it's impossible for you to know that
and that's what it was like for me at
the start of the game when you're
dropped into the game you're given
instructions on how to move and how to
dig that's it that's all you'll ever get
in regards to explicit instructions
what's your objective you don't know how
do I get there you don't know that
either but that's part of the intrigue
when asked for help with the game the
developer mentioned this if you still
have questions keep going that's a quote
that's at the center of this game and I
feel like that's an aspect of game
design that's left out these days in
triple-a titles you always have a
section of your screen devoted to a
waypoint telling you exactly where to go
and exactly how far you've got till you
get there not only does this break
immersion a little but it ruins the need
for you to think critically about where
to go what's happening around you and
how to get there I like the games where
you're dropped into a world and find
your own way through intuition and
pushing your boundaries to see what
works and this doesn't apply just to
waypoints it applies to all gameplay
give me the basics of gameplay and let
me figure out where to go and how to get
don't make the game a giant tutorial
with texts all over the screen teach me
how to play through the gameplay and
Dark Souls does this pretty well with
its boss design for example the first
encounter with the asylum demon teaches
you to observe your environment the
second encounter teaches plunging
attacks and the second boss incorporates
both those things with an optional
environmental plunging attack that a lot
of players probably miss you also learn
that you can block giant hammers goggles
teach weaknesses quelaag teaches you to
watch the boss carefully for moveset
cues for Kings teach you how to cope
with depression and Gwyn rewards you for
learning parrying in my opinion this is
the best way to teach someone how to
play you feel like you've legitimately
become a better player at the end of the
game now I'm not saying all games should
be designed like this but I also feel
like publishers might be afraid of this
sort of game design there are a lot of
people who hate Dark Souls because of it
and many people gave up on that game in
the first few hours because they're used
to being spoon-fed
with more and more triple-a titles
developed with press X to wind gameplay
I feel like publishers fear being on the
other side of that spectrum they'd
rather appeal to everyone rather than
scare away the casuals with a game that
isn't necessarily hard but one that
doesn't tell you where to go at the end
of the day publishers like Namco Bandai
want to bring Dark Souls to a wider
audience which is something we all want
but I get worried when they mention
making the game more accessible
I agree the Dark Souls could definitely
be more accessible in the first few
hours of play
it's a shame so many people missed out
on the game because they got destroyed
from the very start I also think that
the law could be more accessible on the
surface as long as it retains its depth
give me an obvious shallow story for my
first playthrough with a really deep
subplot that exists for those who look
for it give me an extended tutorial that
teaches me the core gameplay better as
long as it leads towards the same
relentless and rewarding difficulty the
most important thing is having a game
that rewards you for being intuitive and
resourceful and that's what I expect
from Dark Souls 2
you